hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to house
we now know a few secrets about this
house
but it's still trying to kill us very
much dead oh i i need to go
so what i need to do i may not get to it
this time but
uh my sister got pulled into the toilet
by the toilet monster
so i have a funny feeling that i'm not
quite done with the whole
uh you know saving everybody thing
which i'm guessing is the objective that
i need to do i'm not a
hundred percent sure but it sure seems
like that's what i need to do
thank you later nerd
that toby kid had it coming if you ask
me toby
i think we could take a break okay
okay and go go go go go go go go
okay oh right right key keep god i've
forgotten everything
in an instant i forget everything uh
here
no drop okay go go go go yes hello
i thank you thank you very much
hi mom don't mind me mom don't mind me
don't mind me mom
this this this okay good good good don't
do any of that okay and then put this
here and then drop this down
here and then hi how you doing i gotta
chop your hand off okay there we go
get that okay then run here
go sister don't go play okay she's not
there yet
okay all right uh shoot up
bam got it nailed it i'm the best uh go
kill the toilet
hey what's up don't mind the gun it was
up all right see you
okay and uh whackums sorry bud
okay so that's good and i imagine
there's gonna be something else
happening
that's gonna prevent a lot of fun the
bucket
the bucket no mom wait no hold on
mom you almost got killed
you almost got killed is there still
gonna be a fire
oh i forgot the fire oh right the fire i
gotta put out the fire
uh okay we're good mom don't slip on
that or if you do
don't okay sploosh okay got it okay cool
[ __ ] it i have a bucket i don't know why
now why do i
oh mom no god damn it
damn it mom oh well that's gonna be a
problem uh
oh [ __ ] mom maybe i should get the
shotgun shell uh just in case i need to
shoot mom
i mean i don't think that this is the
proper way to go about things but you
know
at least i have this mom don't get up
whatever you do don't get up
just don't get up don't get up ma oh i
forgot about the goddamn carpet
ooh i forgot about the goddamn carpet i
forgot about the goddamn carpet
i forgot about the carpet i forgot about
the carpet i forgot about the carpet
okay i was i was really frazzled that
time anyway so it doesn't matter
wake up cat many adventures for us today
kitty
thank you place
grab thank you bucket first because
mom's gonna die and then i'll worry
about putting out the fire later
oh there we go take that bam don't go
to the bathroom bam done all right
eventually i need to put out the fire
but i know that
well maybe i could run grab it okay i'm
gonna run
mom don't slip don't slip don't slip
don't slip don't slip
okay here we go put out the fire okay
good mom don't slip
don't slip don't slip don't slip don't
slip
caught it nailed it i'm the best now i'm
gonna get the shotgun shell just in case
i need something to shoot
ah yeah okay so far so good
so far so good mom you alive in there
okay good good good good good good good
i'm gonna take this bucket then
i'm here i'm ready eat good
good okay i'm gonna keep an eye on
sister
well i'm not gonna touch the carpet
hello it's easter
lost easter i know it's a tragedy oh
it's so
oh that's a problem yeah i know right
yeah hey i hate snails more than i hate
father don't play bowling ball oh
what's going on here oh no wait no
stop nope stop what are you doing no no
no no what how get the ax
put what that
what how's it i do
what what do i how do
what do i do what what
what do i do mom
mom mom
oh no oh
my god
oh no oh no papa
what no oh no papa
papa no oh no
oh no papa what do you have to say about
this papa
oh boy okay that does nothing
okay well um
okay well that went horribly wrong is
there a way to like
break that stool or something maybe i
could like put the doll
on the stool that's weird but maybe
maybe it would remind them
okay go kill the toilet
okay and then maybe with this
will you hold me yes maybe put the i
don't know why
but this feels like something to do no
okay how about that
[Music]
okay maybe not what about what if i just
freaking
okay there yeah that that must be it yes
good question mark good that
probably good hi mom i gotta put out the
fire
you're gonna die if i put out the fire
you're gonna die you're gonna die you're
gonna die you're gonna die oh no oh no
put out the fire
oh no oh
god
okay um so ma there's a kind of a fire
um you didn't die though so that was
good i should have been a little quicker
i was so indecisive about it but um
anyway hey ma how you doing snail off
your head it's unsanitary
yeah okay hey lady um
how are you feeling tonight your sister
is pure of heart the house has her in
his icy grip she can't fight back he
must guide her safety okay well let me
go check
i guess unless the carpet's gonna get in
my way oh carpet's not happy about me
okay can i oh i can't slip by maybe i
can maybe i can
oh maybe i could oh i'm gonna go no
okay you know what that's not i'm
assuming she's good i'm assuming she's
good
not sure what else to do i mean like
clearly there's
obviously a conflagration there and uh
clearly it's going to get worse and
clearly there's nothing i can do about
is there something that happens to you
like do you die or something do you do
something
hi run along now dear there's much to be
done ah yeah well
you know i don't really have much to do
wait the lights go out
oh no
what is that what is that what is that
oh my god
what what that just happens it's easter
seaster what do i do what do i do
i got a sandwich something going to say
oh god not that guy
oh no oh no
okay goodbye i guess um i'm gonna go
check on seaster
you're alive i feel so alone but you're
alive
okay so i fixed you or i kept you safe
i didn't fix you oh hey p-paw
hey you wouldn't kill me uh in front of
seaster would you
okay but okay progress
progress okay
all right but progress
okay so some kind of weird ocarina of
time
hand comes out of the fridge and grabs
mom
oh i can put something in front of the
fridge like uh i bet if i put the
bowling ball there let me go chop up the
toilet turlet okay chop up the
bam okay you don't need to worry about
oh my god
oh my god wait wait wait sister oh god i
ran out of stoma
i don't need it muhammad a stamina there
we go muhammad stamina
go grab the thing put out the fur
grab this don't die mom mom don't die
[Music]
okay put it back put it back
get back put it back put that there
bowling ball bam it'll never open
it opens okay um okay maybe it won't
open when
the time comes get the shotgun shell i
got to get the shotgun shell that's what
i do
okay get the shotgun shell okay
and be ready to shoot it i'm coming ma
i'm on the way don't worry ma
i'm here mama mama
hey mom how you doing
you good ma you good oh hey bud how you
doing
how you doing how are you feeling
tonight it's a shame about your sister
she's been a bit depressed yeah i know i
know i know i know
okay so what time did that happen
it was evening it's later it was like
nine
maybe it'd be better if i chop it okay
where is it uh
to chop okay two to the left in case
that doesn't work
chop seems chop makes sense it's a hand
so i chop it okay okay okay okay okay
okay lights went out okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
oh my god oh my god oh my god
what is that oh my god oh my god
what is that holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
what do i do what do i do look at the
titties on you oh no
oh no what do i do what do i do
[Music]
wait wait a minute wait
but wait though but wait
what do you do bear trap
bear trap bear trap okay i'm gonna try
and do without it
yeah i'm going for it yeah i can make it
i can make it i can make it okay good
i made it okay so i have the bear trap
i'm gonna just put this
bear trap down here well okay i don't
need it for the hand
so i'm gonna wait because there is time
okay and coming in coming in coming
okay ha okay i'm gonna lay down the bear
trap
okay air drops down come on come on come
on come on do something do something do
something do something
oh it did it it did it okay shoot it no
it didn't do it
oh my god what it didn't do anything
oh i didn't get the bullet i didn't get
the bullet can you save me
save me oh not you not you oh my god not
you oh my god not you
not you please not you oh my god please
not you okay
um all right i'm gonna i'm gonna shoot
you i'm gonna shoot you big
take some of that well i'm screwed uh
eat get eaten by the rat fight the rat
fight the rat fight the rat rat fight
fight for me fight for me rat
fight for me right
the bear trap did nothing the shotgun
did nothing there's got to be something
else right there would have to be
something else in the house that could
like
fall on it or it could fall through
somewhere
that makes sense this is just going to
be exploratory the chandelier no
you couldn't no you couldn't do this
chandelier
could you do the chandelier is there a
way to get the chandelier to fall on
them no i don't
think so the bookshelf maybe i could get
the bookshelf fall over somehow
right there's that doll up there i
wonder if that's something
okay come here you and then go down yes
okay easy easy okay i don't think it's
about getting in the fight with a rat
although that is something to try but
that doesn't seem right you know what i
mean is there something down here
what about another level nah damn it
okay there's got to be something
here right
maybe maybe it is maybe it is to do with
that no i mean
i'm going to lose this one so
maybe an alternative maybe this is an
alternative
no oh
oh wait wait
wait a minute oh god oh god oh god
there's more than one shotgun shell
wait a minute okay but where's the other
ones
are there more sorry cat
are there more there might be more
where would there be more is there
another place
no wait oh where would that
oh this feels right this feels right
but where would it be right where would
it be where would it be oh where would
it be
maybe two shotgun shells is enough not
represent sure
so sister's safe let me see if i can go
get the other shotgun shell while i have
a chance
no god damn it um unless oh god
nope ah that ain't happening i should
have gotten it god damn it oh my god
oh my god okay i can't unless i can
then i will yes i can is it on the
ground still
yes okay i got it so i now have two
shotgun shells
maybe it is a thing where it needs two
hi
maybe i want a sandwich and a sandwich
maybe we could offer a sandwich
so there's gotta be something to kill it
maybe if dad comes home maybe dad could
kill it maybe they could fight each
other
maybe that is it not the craziest idea i
mean all these are kind of crazy ideas
so i'm not going to be too
upset about trying them all i i do know
that i can run around it
which is interesting like i could run
around it probably
in the piano room it's kind of late
weird oh
pop okay and then i'm gonna go ahead and
lay that down later nerd
uh there we go okay so
it's mad
oh yeah oh you're much quicker than i
remember hey uh don't kill my cat by the
way
holy [ __ ] okay so
uh oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god
okay okay so that is interesting maybe i
could just run
circles around it you know oh god oh god
oh god
okay okay okay oh my god you are much
quicker than i thought you'd be
oh okay kitty
you uh oh i never got this oh my god i
never got the other oh my god
i never got the other shotgun shell how
did i not realize that
oh my god okay so i got to make another
loop which i know i can make
so i just got to make another loop grab
that shotgun shell try for another shot
okay whoa
it did not seem possible
the day stretched on and the darkness
grew bold the curse on your house
insurmountable but now the house is
still
the endless gnawing dread replaced with
a warm meal
and you return to your old familiar life
a game by chris ratz and isaac knight
i did it
i did it it said just to come
i don't i guess i did it
oh
uh oh i didn't do it oh
god damn you oh my god
he's gonna make me feel like an idiot so
you think you've beaten it oh my god
well i'm afraid you're terribly wrong
yeah i figured as much there's no way to
stop it
no matter how hard you and that snail
try it never ends
god damn it i really thought that you
know up for a second there i thought i
was like oh
[ __ ] i did it i saved everybody but
apparently that's not the way to go okay
good
i'm glad to know that that's that's
fantastic i should have known because my
journal is yeah i should have known that
my journal is nowhere near full
i did everything for a brief moment
everything was back to normal it didn't
matter
i still woke up again in this room i
can't take much more of this
so there are many more things it wants
me to do horrible things maybe it will
stop if i listen
[Music]
is that something that might be
something there might be something to
that
whoa what is that oh that's new there's
blood on the clock
okay i i don't know how much i'm gonna
try
horrible things horrible things it said
horrible
so horrible is what i'm doing
sorry oh my god i'm sorry uh it said
horrible so horrible is
i mean you get one where you save
everybody and then you get another where
you
don't do that sorry mom my apology mom
oh boy well that's not good i oh
okay bye hey what's up
[Music]
oh don't laugh to me i
go oh hi
[Music]
that was a thing what's this a child who
i sense potential in you
one last soul remains but where unless
soul remains but
what do you mean one last soul remains
oh i know what soul i think i know where
the last one is so i'm gonna go
uh take care of that um
just gonna go do that howdy neighbor you
there neighbor
like a good neighbor like a good
neighbor
maybe intelligently stayed away maybe
you gotta be the first one i kill i
don't know
i don't know
okay i know okay you show up at this
point
okay
oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay
well i wasn't ready for that that'll be
it for this episode
uh i'll i'll play this again because
clearly there's more stuff here to see
uh so there's a lot to explore like a
lot a lot to explore but it's so fun
because there's so many different ways
that you can
go about the environment it's super fun
hey have you checked out distractible
if you haven't bob's gonna elbow drop
you from the third floor
and then wade will follow it up with the
people's elbow
and then i'm gonna double elbow you into
the dirt
so link's in the description thank you
everybody and as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye